Kamala Harris putting the fear of God
into every Democrat who might sit out
2024 the vice president strutting like a
girl boss as she claims to be ready to
take over the big job and that's the
presidency you go girl President Biden
sent her overseas to Indonesia and she
came back in his place for a big Summit
and that's where she reminded voters
that she's one sandbag away from the top
job
you feel prepared for that possibility
uh and a serving his vice president
prepared you for for that job yes Joe
Biden's going to be fine so that is not
going to come to fruition but let us
also understand that every vice
president
every vice president
understands that when they take the oath
that they must be very clear about the
responsibility they may have
to take over the job of being president
I am no different oh yes you are but
before she ascends the throne kamla
still has to play the game in butter up
her boss
our president
has been an extraordinary leader who has
accomplished
things that previous presidents hoped
and dreamed and promised they would do
and did not achieve I see
how his ability to understand issues
and weave through complex issues in a
way that no one else can to make smart
and important decisions on behalf of the
American people have played out
who is she talking about and if you dare
get in her way there will be hell to pay
kamala's allies are warning Gavin Newsom
to stay away from a presidential run or
they'll tar and feather him as a racist
one strategist saying quote when you had
people who were trying to test the
waters the party rose up and made it
clear to those individuals who were
mostly white men that to disrespect a
vice president would not be well
received by women and people of color
within the party they got a little bit
of a smack in the face Harold This Is
Amazing by the way it's great to see you
at the table hope the US Open is
treating you well thank you you got a
tan I can see thank you you know um so
it's going to be racist to pick Gavin
over Kamala but it's not racist to keep
supporting the oldest white dude on
Earth how do you make sense of this good
to be back a couple of things I'm not
surprised that she would say what she
said about being vice president and and
being ready to just step in that's what
vice presidents do I don't know of any
vice president in the history of the
country that would not say that two if
for some reason Joe Biden does not run
uh and vice president Harris decides to
run I think she would expect has to
expect to have a number of competitors
because people believe this race here
would position him to serve for four to
eight years especially if it's president
Trump there's a belief on the Democrat
side that he can be defeated uh and so
you will have you would have a
competitive Marketplace which I don't
think should surprise should surprise
anyone a take issue I know Karen Finney
and I like her a lot I don't think it's
racist or sexist to say that someone
else believes that they have the goods
and they have the ability to speak to
the American people meet them where they
are and help them rise to a different
point just because they're a white male
or an Hispanic male or black male who
met whatever maybe they have to go
before the voters and I understand there
may be some hurt feelings on the part of
some in the party that the vice
president would not be the front runner
if something like this were to happen
it's it I think President Biden is going
to run for reelection but I wouldn't I
say I'm not one to always reduce things
to race and I think this is one of those
moments where we ought to show some
restraint oh never judge you know how
the VP is supposed to be like America's
insurance policy it's actually she's
Joe's insurance policy right isn't that
hilarious it's like he he has to stay in
because she can't be president well
everyone knows I mean why would you
impeach Joe Biden I mean look at what
you get but what I think is so
fascinating is when she says that
um you know she can tackle the
presidency she's up to it I mean how can
she do that when she has no apparent
interest in anything that she's doing
she's the borders are she's been the
borders are and she hasn't been to the
border and I think it's 803 days she had
one trip there uh and according to this
new book uh it there there's a part of
it that says that she doesn't want to
work on women's issues or anything
having to do with race well I like her
now oh wow but but I think you know what
I think people want honesty when you get
out there and you say I've watched Joe
Biden and he is in a position where he
can handle things and resolve them in a
way where no one else can or in a way
that no one else can the guy needs a
cheat sheet to figure out when to stand
up when to sit down when to leave he was
at the award ceremony when was it
yesterday he left it soon it by the way
without his mask because he puts the
award on the the war veteran and and he
just leaves he just leaves in the middle
of it you know uh and and let me just
say one thing about Gavin Newsom I mean
you know
I identity politics go only goes a
certain to a certain length I think you
know when they start playing identity
politics that she is entitled because
she is that person I mean to disrespect
someone you have to have respect for
them in the first instance and I'm not
so sure she has that what do you make of
all this Dana it's this is what happens
with identity politics you end up making
bad choices and then the other choices
are kind of kept out when you look at
some of the polling from Democrats about
Kamala Harris that's what I would focus
on because she's not going to win over a
republican she knows that they do need
to win over Independence yes but she's
also in a position of having to convince
Democrats that she could do it so that's
actually a harder thing it's all also
getting very late for any other Democrat
to stand up a national campaign that's
other than the vice president so I think
if there was a target of opportunity for
somebody like Gavin Newsom or whoever
might be at the stable to take a shot
that window is closing quite rapidly
watching her at this event okay fine
that's great whatever it's fine but
compare that to what you'll see this
weekend Joe Biden leaves for India
tomorrow it's a big meeting that's sort
of she's at the sort of the pre-meeting
and so you'll see his interactions with
those leaders compared and will he be in
a mask I don't know the other thing
about this notion that Democrats would
send a shot to Gavin Newsom saying don't
you dare do you remember go back in the
way back machine with me in 2008 the
late Bill Richardson former governor and
somebody who had worked at the UN for
Bill Clinton he made a decision to
endorse Barack Obama over Hillary
Clinton even though he was a real good a
major Clinton loyalist partly because he
wanted to win and he thought that the
way that they could win was with Obama
it turns out he was right there you go
well history lesson wow see Jesse do you
have any history lessons I wonder did
she have to wear that funny shirt
no no sometimes they make him make it
right yeah yeah so that's why Joe didn't
go he didn't want to wear the funny
shirt yeah he's going to India though
he's going to India where they're
Indians so wear a funny shirt make you
wear that shirt yeah
do you know how sometimes when you have
to do your eye test at the doctor and
they go to the lower level yeah and you
start going
c t that's how Kamala talks and she's
just guessing and she's just leaving
wide gaps in between statements the
answer that she gave on the vice
president being able to take over the
presidency I didn't think was good
Harold here's why there's extra
sensitivity to the question because he's
the oldest president we've ever had so
she's not like all the other past vice
presidents so there's extra scrutiny on
her and that answer and that answer she
showed way too much like you just say
Joe's healthy I don't even consider it a
possibility
that's it and now we're doing a segment
on it because she's coming for the
throne Gavin Newsom is probably going to
challenge if something happens to Joe
and doesn't matter about race or gender
the money is going to tell you who's the
nominee that's it people don't care
you'll see where the money goes visually
to see her strut through the pageantry
was the first time I could actually
imagine her as president and
I just can't take her seriously knowing
all the ridiculous Things She Said
despite the Pomp and Circumstance and
the great choreography
I just reminded of the fact that she
loves Venn diagrams and that she you
know she hasn't been to Europe either I
just can't get that out of my head you
know you had that quote from the book by
four the judge said she said shouldn't
wouldn't do anything about race or
gender then she said but I want a
majority of my staff to be
African-American women and then she quit
her borders our job yep it just doesn't
give you a lot of confidence that she
didn't want to be around minorities
look is that your interpretation no I'm
just saying hypothesizing that's what
I've heard that's what you've heard
those are your sources yes maybe it's
reciprocal because they're all quitting
if she does run for circumstances
presented so she'll have to win a
primary and if she wins a primary uh
right well she have to win one prop well
the Democratic prayer made the caucuses
she will be a stronger candidate if she
has to do it in if I were her team I'd
welcome that kind of challenge because
one of a republican she's gonna have to
show and again this is where this is
hypothetical Joe Biden's going to be the
novice yeah but you're crazy what's
what's interesting is that she did she
didn't laugh her way through that answer
about being Vice about being president
she didn't giggle she always Giggles
yeah progress she's changing what did
you guys remember when everything was
about Trump lying we're not he just lies
and lies and lies have you ever seen
that much lying we've just I mean I mean
weren't they supposed to be better than
this I mean that was a that was minutes
pure minutes of lying there with a
straight face
Straight Ahead some breaking news looks
like Hunter Biden is about to get
indicted hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else